hello and welcome to this video on
playing never rematch yeah I also never
do a rematch here yeah but it's a video
format so I'm playing a Kings in yet
just for a change then we kick the main
line okay yeah this is difficult you
know if somebody this is a very young
aggressive and very principled variation
and I'm not really the expert yeah this
is the main line yeah I know when I was
a kid that the smooth was played which
is like yes 20 26 27 years ago that was
the first time I played the Kings Indian
I had two kings Indian stretcher said
was one of the first openings that are
played against you form and and then I
scrapped it because I had no score
whatsoever I didn't play I didn't score
well and then I rediscovered it in the
mid 1990s and actually it's quite very
well with it and only later discarded it
yeah just because I wanted to do
something else to something new and then
I played the Slav no not because I felt
the Kings onion was terrible also it I
was just curious in new things what I'm
doing here is just like winging it
basically I wonder actually if 96 now is
a good move I probably have to take this
yeah maybe I can gonna take take night
c-5 it looks very shaky okay this is a
more conservative approach I think
usually that signals right attention to
play the night to f2 but that is very
slow okay so no night to have to what is
he doing them okay
getting ready to play G form if I can
play it without having to play h5 I'm
not unhappy about it I know he goes back
okay so g4 or not yeah I think I can't
do it immediately and there is no real
reason to him to push h5 first if he
takes on g4 yeah I guess I would go Here
I am
this is probably the most dynamic option
that like 93 is a really serious idea
and if he has to take it I will develop
with the tempo now that's good it's not
a bad position at all
that's nice tempo the only misplaced
piece currently is my night I have to
get this into the game I can manage that
I will probably be in excellent shape
how to do it though
98 to f6 King in the corner nitrogen f6
or maybe I maybe I'm just attacking
without the piece hmm well no is it
going for some c5 business Bishop h3
immediately it doesn't really just not
yet convinced I'm going to do that I
mean I always like to have all the
pieces in play and the knight on f6 is
definitely fine and it's not like the
ambition to win six change here and I
think I'm going to take it there is no
reason not to okay it's not threatening
to catch I am so I'm going to take I
just wonder
if I'm taking it here jinglin c6 I don't
know maybe a six is an idea for him okay
if I get it to have six the night it
just going to be it's attacking before
but it doesn't threaten something
directly I wonder if I allow a six if
that is bad if that is bad for me if he
takes with the bishop I can I would have
sacrificed the exchange and here I try
to place his six it's so not so easy him
it really isn't
I mean he gave me the material that the
bishop on one of eight is simply not not
a good piece at the very moment ok c6 I
got d6 covered so this is something that
I can play like purely technically I
mean I can play it so I wonder a Mook a6
is very likely happening I think I'm
going to do that at least the bishop
gets a little bit of extra scope only 5
oh that I didn't see at all and he
threatening to jump to f7 okay it's not
good
maybe this one having f3 on the radar
let's go f3 and now isn't that some way
here to use his bad king position it
should be I don't see it however not
easy him threatens to check that again
and again it's getting really annoying
him not really great you can still check
out now and then bloody night is hanging
using this game is rather rather
terrible it really shouldn't happen we
wanted to play knight c6 but that
doesn't work simply
mm-hmm it's not really doing a good job
here you know I know I know I'm winning
this probably
okay wow that was weird
that was weird I mean he blundered the
exchange it was not a clear position at
least it didn't look very clear to me
yeah I went a five I think this is still
a means that is played but don't ask me
what the theoretical evaluation is I
know that they normally go night g6m and
then there's a five and c5 and whatever
now okay I went a 593 b6 before and now
it's okay yeah I think there is also
there are also ideas like that I think
I've seen this before but well I'm I was
basically making things up here long and
then went yeah rook f6 I think knight c6
was strong but you didn't do it I
thought that was strong simply because
after the capture it's not so clear
where I'm going
yeah Knight f6 would be good but that's
it's the rook and this is looking weird
due to a5 yeah exactly and it is
exploding because I cannot sorry I
cannot take here as c5 is hanging like
this yeah I think this would have been
strong this should be one looks a little
bit on the snow side and I think it's
it's one reason why I got a good
position shortly afterwards yeah he took
it and now I'm immediately threatening
93 so but the capture is probably giving
me you should
it's already King h8 yeah I wasn't sure
about that I mean maybe there is a
direct way to attack the engine gives
2076 almost i always have a desire to
improve the worst place peace and this
is the reason behind the smooth you know
maybe not the best at the end of so like
that yeah that land a sex change but
things are not so super simple in fact
okay so now f3 is good oh wow that's a
strong line f3 g 395 oh okay yeah that
looks fantastic I'm threatening route g3
with made ya look g3 pawn takes Queen
takes that's made on g2 so let's say
this year just to show I'm taking this
and that is made and everything edge one
of the group G 2 should win yeah that's
also as it's going to checkmate Queen g3
okay you made here here so that was very
strong yeah okay ultimately I was too
tempted to just take it take take I drew
create yeah I saw the entrance to likes
my play and I think this should be a win
with best play but I did not really
manage best play and it is still fairly
complicated there are some white has
those active pieces so three pieces are
creating some counter plan
yeah with hindsight probably 94 is not
great Queen g8 wins okay threatening to
take on d6 and
looking at G - okay yeah it's not that's
not easy now he's got some activity and
he's got a pawn for the exchange it's
not too bad
I have three g3 Bishop h6 finally have
wanted to activate this but it's
probably that is probably ill-advised
yeah Queen e2 was strong and now he has
this big playing with Knight f7 here in
94 was already strong yeah yeah I'm just
in trouble it's a and it's very
difficult to play with no time
it's neither seven or such a menacing
idea I probably have to return the
exchange which this is my chief always
killing me completely there that
probably also wins you know an idea of
seven that that is the game oh I can
just take the other night I saw that
yeah yeah I thought I have this but
obviously his level okay Wow okay now
there should be three wins for me most
when half Queen b5 check yeah well here
it was just like movement movie and that
is bad group g7 a both had no time
the ante I totally did not see that 96
is plundering it to mate in one
I wanted to discover or an IP find what
the discovery on the glimmer has just
made
yeah and somehow somehow he didn't put
it away yeah cool Quincy one it's just
just a blonde I am yeah it is out of
checks I mean you're gonna almost he can
check here it I can't even go to age
five what I wanted and now he is mated
yeah that was very lucky but this is
kind of yeah quite typical of the Kings
Indian in some way respect you sometimes
have to win the game more than once
because there's always this you know
often encountered shed taking chance on
the King thanks a lot for watching